hello everyone
20 years ago latin american cinema
exploded around the world from mexico
the names of alejandro gonzalez
guillermo del toro alfonso coron
rapidly became a reference for everyone
around the world and not just from
mexico from brazil there was walter
sales fernando mireles padilla from
argentina trapezo lucrecia martel many
names from latin america that were
suddenly setting the bar really high
there was no cool festival if you didn't
had a latin american film
names like wild tales roma fantastic
woman titles like embrace of the serpent
no the milk sorrow latin american films
have been celebrated around the globe
and especially at the academy awards but
we're not stopping there many filmmakers
are crossing over and expanding their
careers into the english language
industry
and those stories need to be heard
in the following panel the amazing
producer rosa bosch will have a
passionate debate with four filmmakers
that are already shooting in english
that have so much to say and experiences
to share so please stay for the panel
enjoy the panel
and remember tell your own stories
you